I've been using samsung's new Galaxy
buds and I'm Way more impressed than
that thought it would be I started off
with sn+ where the setup process was
familiar but less fluid than the air
pods and after I was greeted with a
galaxy wearable app that allowed me to
change the EQ for all audio which is
something that I've wanted from the air
pods since they're released
I enjoyed using them with an Android
phone and that got me thinking are the
galaxy pods worth buying and using as an
alternative to the air pots if you own
an iPhone to get it right out there yes
I think for a lot of iOS users the
galaxy buds may be a better high but not
for everyone and I'll tell you why in
just a bit let's start out with the
first enticement of the buds and that's
the price $129 isn't that much lower
than 159 Apple charges for their super
successful air pods but if you care
about wireless charging that will cost
you another $40 $70 more than the galaxy
buds that come with wireless charging
built-in not everybody cares about that
though but what does matter to all is
battery life the Galaxy buds last six
hours instead of the five but the
charging case only offers seven
additional hours compared to close to 20
with the air pods the cradle cases work
similarly but the galaxy buds is larger
overall the next enticement is a seal
design with multiple ear buds and
wingtips to make sure you get a great
seal and fit even though the air pods
fit me perfectly this has been the
biggest complaint I've heard for those
who they don't fit and a huge reason for
iPhone users to go with the galaxy buds
another thing I love is the fact that
they are practically flush with my ears
when I have them in meaning I could use
them with the helmet the seal design is
great for times where you want to cut
down background noise and even partially
protect your hearing if you're using an
Android device you'll have an ambient
sound feature but since we don't have
the galaxy wear it will happen iOS that
will be missing along with that you
won't happen all around EQ controller
but the air pods don't have this either
instead you can make adjustments on an
app top basis and honestly I didn't find
that I needed to since the default
settings were my favorite out of all the
options that Samsung gives the highs are
crisp mids are balanced and the bass is
worlds ahead of the air Potts thanks to
the seals design if you care about sound
quality the galaxy butts are definitely
ahead and sound impressive for the price
so we have a lower price wireless
charging compact design better sound and
fit for most and along with that I px 2
for sweat and light splash resistance
but what are the downsides if you use
them with an iPhone the biggest one for
me is the fact that they aren't as
seamless as the
earpods with the w1 or h1 chip I love
that the air pods get automatically
added to all of my iCloud devices and I
just opened the case put them in and
they Auto pair you won't get the same
fluid experience but it's still not that
bad they work like any other bluetooth
headphones so connect them once to each
device and then if you want to switch
from your Mac to your iPhone go into the
Bluetooth settings and manually hit
connect of course if you only own an
iPhone not an iPad or a Mac then this
probably won't matter to you now in the
batteries widget you'll see the battery
life but unfortunately it's not broken
down into each bud and you also can't
see the cases charge levels like you can
with the air pods on the plus side you
could still single tap to pause and
unpause double tap to skip a song and
even hold down to invoke Siri you can
also use the built-in mics just like
with any other Bluetooth headphones
overall I'm very impressed with the
Galaxy buds the sound quality and
feature set is fantastic for the price
and even if you're using an iPhone they
are a great option with very little
downsides compared to Apple's offering
so I can conference a yes they are worth
it for iPhone users this has been max
with max tech if you want to see more
videos like this hit that little circle
above and let me know if you'd consider
picking up the galaxy buds in the
comments section below